finora avete soltanto creduto di
assistere a delle operazioni serie ma il
bello arriva adesso raga sigla
[Musica]
[Applauso]
per gli adulti ragazzi e benvenute
questo nuovo video io sono vari j
oggi iniziamo finalmente i trapianti in
ambulanza che per la gioia dei pazienti
sarà epico allora laga come al solito la
gente mi devono per i [ __ ]
prima di iniziare perché non sono
contenti se no si parlate con la
bottiglia stronzi
sentite un attimo allora che abbiamo
effettuato finora delle operazioni
normali ovvero in sala operatoria ma
come gli ho fatto vedere alla fine
dell'ultimo episodio dello scorso in
pratica ci sono le stesse operazioni da
effettuare in ambulanza sarà fantastico
laga e dopo di queste quando finirò di
fare queste mi si sbloccherà
l'operazione finale che è quella nello
spazio a gravità zero
raga sarà epico vi giuro non vedo l'ora
ma per ora direi di iniziare col
trapianto di cuore in ambulanza vai
cos'è sono carico cazzo allora perfetto
ci siamo sarà fantastico nel nello
scorso episodio è stato un delirio e
l'ho soltanto provato cioè nel senso non
ero lì a effettuare veramente
l'operazione come si deve ma stavolta ci
sono tutta stronzo verini non morire che
voglio fare una bella figura
nessuno se l'aspetta in capo al primo
forte ma io ce la farò ce la farò anche
se sta saltando tutti in aria ma certo
manca anche qui vedo come l'anno scorso
episodio grazie a chi serve questo
aramis consigliere incastro soltanto un
secondo in mezzo alle costole
perché devo mettermi seconda posti
guanti allora ok poi cos'è allora grazie
mille per avermelo tenuto ci siamo
ragazzi ovviamente raga mi ero
dimenticato che prima devo togliere la
parte in superficie se no non va bene
e allora vai col martello allora parchi
superficie sempre uguale via la radio
cazzo
no che mi sveglio il paziente e se si
sveglia sono cazzi è un po complicata la
cosa ma certo addio vi sta morendo e ora
anche visto
datemi la siringa la siringa brainshare
la siringa cazzo e questa e quella verde
togliti trapano del cazzo
devo riuscire a prendere dalla cadevo
prende la siringa valigia prima donna
che tra problemi da cazzo premi la
sorpresa vai fagliela subito subito
addio non ci credo torna anche
salvataggio il paziente ragazzi che
volta di curda cazzo e togliamo glielo
immediatamente sta morendo nota rai
bastarda la radio ma se mi ammazzo il
paziente cerca di essere su radio maria
perché devi pregare che non ti butti
giorni è un'impresa se ne faccio ma più
sta morendo
raga raga bastardo bastardo non morire
allora fatevi prendere sto cazzo no no
oh mio dio sull'occhio e allora sto
martello vista rompe prendilo cazzo
prendi no ce l'abbiamo fatta dagli una
martellata dai ma che cazzo mi fa
piacere che voi dormire con gli attrezzi
però mi serve mi serve per operarti di
da me lo ridà ok
raga dobbiamo fare in fretta perché
questo mi muore è un problema spacchiamo
tutto perfetto ragazze la facciamo ce la
facciamo piano o mio dio tigre ma ha già
perso 12 litri di sangue come è
possibile allora ragazzi se non faccio
da anni ce la dovremo pino corvette dal
martello di rientro non va bene
devo top ma perché non stai fermo porca
[ __ ] e vai col laser teorici no no no
se si accende sul garda gli ho fatto un
tatuaggio sulla fronte va beh l'ho preso
in tempo
no state fermi che ed europea state
fermi risate dritto caps ce la fate
andare dritti ragazzetta ma chi cazzo
stai guidando l'ambulanza si jv sarà
andreas andate dritto che ok
minchia un'ora il tettuccio sto prendo
fatemi fatemi spegnere fatemi spegnere
ok siringa ragano dove la siringa a mio
zio
la radio rai che non ce la farò è
impossibile è impossibile perchè perchè
c'è mezza sala operatoria all'interno
del mio paziente una matita e 3 bisturi
all'interno del paziente perché già temi
perché raga non ha senso
la sea la siringa prendi st potuta
siringa prima che mi prendi la prendi la
dose ma togliti ma che casa perché è
pieno di oh oh dio odia vi sta morendo
mai
bye bye set ok alla ragazzi il paziente
è salvo per ora è salvo al quale
nell'orecchio ea mezza sala operatoria
all'interno matite bisturi di tutto devo
riuscire a salvarlo
se riesco a fare sta cosa devono fare
santo cazzo aragno dio mio l'arancio
fuori giuro che se mi dà ancora fastidio
la latina il seghetto il seghetto ma che
cazzo ma si può
maledizione no io al seghetto laga mi
sta morendo di nuovo dove l'ho lasciata
la siringa mangiatelo mangiatelo ghini
mangiate no guardate che botta s'è preso
con paranormal organi
raga è un drago è un del ii impossibile
e imposti c'è un pancreas che vola
perché voi sapete come ho però io di
solito ovvero i primi trapianti primi
due vanno sempre male ma il terzo
funziona anche se raga vi giuro è
imposti è difficilissimo c'è una cosa
impressionante
però direi che forse una tattica buona
cerco di usare un po di tattiche
stavolta diversamente dalle altre
operazioni perché se no non ce la farò
mai è impossibile è impossibile
devo riuscire a buttare di fuori
dall'ambulanza tutto quello che non
serve tipo estintori robe del genere
perché mi fanno fuori il paziente prima
che lo faccia fuori io caccia i minuti
contati il suo poveraccio se lo
ammazziamo pure prima non ha senso
vabbè allora il martello non v'è perché
il maltempo ok martella andato via via
cotta alla lega buttiamo giù di tutto
questo è il mio compito però che è
perfetto sia chiusa quindi partiamo di
merda a vista casa ok via no sei
incastrato
ma che cazzo non la testa mi serve la
stessa del paziente via tutto
gli ha tolto la radio la radio via la
radio prendetevela dai dai
beh ce l'ho fatta via la radio
[ __ ] anche il becker non serve a
nulla
devi buttarlo giù buttalo giù brutta
l'ho giocato sì ok ragazzi anche la
matita non la matita mi serve per
filmare il cuore quindi quella mi serve
ancora
e già che ci sono di firmo il polmone va
vj ok cose oppure su cosa non souvenir
mela vuoi dare di tra spontanea volontà
e allora te lo puoi riprendere quindi
liveri proseguire allora via col laser
vice para
fai gli hawks skywalker devo riuscire no
fermo fermo si j stai fermo fermo
ok grandissimo ce l'hai fatta allora
vediamo se riesco a tagliare tipo questo
anche non lo so che devo tagliare
precisamente ok
direi che basta vai così ferma tutto
fermato ok
devo togliere i polmoni devo togliere i
polmoni ma il paziente mi sta morendo
via ai polmoni via tutto
raga sta morendo io non lo so ma come
cazzo sarà l'operazione al cervello così
cioè io quella di reni ci ho messo un
secolo a farla normalmente
dell'ambulanza annunciava farò mai sarà
impossibile direi di decidere il quale
se riesco senza un polmone
ci prova a farcela lo stesso non so se
ce la faccio ragazzi non ci credo dolci
che odi o no non vi morire adesso ti
prego non adesso non adesso
non adesso c'è la stavo facendo cazzo
raga io non ci voglio fottutamente
credere ce l'avevo fa l'avevo tolto il
cuore la parte pd c'è dovevo prendere
l'altro cuore metterglielo dentro avevo
finito a potevo riuscire a farcela la
martella
via via frutto via la radio via ogni
cosa la regola odio no no che mi sta
morendo di dami la siringa siringa
ceiling la siringa la siringa la siringa
laga ce la devo fare prendi la 3t misero
punto ma l'inizio no raga questo no mi
sono punto mi sono drogato
ok allora ce la farò raga ce la farò da
drogato un'opera tedacà in ambulanza da
drogato fare un'operazione chirurgica
mentre si j guida l'ambulanza se riesco
a se riesco voglio che dottor house mi
faccio una scultura c'è veramente
assurdo raga non sarà anche se sta
tagliando nel punto giusto non vedo e mi
sta morendo se non vedo un cazzo se l'ho
tagliato e non l'ho tagliato non vedo
nulla andiamo sulla fiducia facciamo
finta che l'ho tagliato perché non vedo
pazzo
raga e imposte sono drogato non ci
riesco devo togliere devo togliere sta
roba sia levati porca [ __ ] black jack
l'ho tolto via via il polonio perfetto
seguito all ha detto a radio il bisturi
e il bisturi veloci datemi un bisturi ce
ne sono 250 ad atene 11 su questo dai
vai con questo possiamo fare la gara da
drogato ragazze riescono a drogato il
video ai preferiti patemisco regalo se
riesco però impossibile
allora ragazzi devo riuscire a togliere
il cuore è riuscito a togliere il cuore
è impossibile toglierlo da drogato c'è
già non vedo cazzo dai raga la siringa
da siringa no la siringa e caduta frega
il cuore è andato il cuore andato e al
non ci credo dai dai dai dai dai st 39
mettilo potenti poiché in tutto contro
st 39 non ci credo il 40 è uscito da
solo non ci voglio credere
allora ragazze la posso fare 34 dai dai
dai
ce lo guardate quanto è rimasto a 32 con
ragazzi non ci posso credere come cazzo
fatto non ci credo che a questo merita
un mi piace
non so come ho fatto finora è stato
assurdo e ho fatto una cosa gli epica
non lo so neanche io raga dottor faqi
che risolve tutto finì ragazzi ce
l'abbiamo fatta in una maniera
incredibile
non so come ho fatto da drogato in
un'ambulanza mentre mi guidava un pazzo
maniaco l'ambulanza col paziente morente
senza siringa perché mi ero drogato e
non riusciva abbiamo prenderla
[ __ ] chi mi chiama
ho fatto una cosa epica la faccia vostra
e vabbé [ __ ] telefono e tutto
quanto trovo un caracas selvi dove è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video attuate nella descrizione se
non siete ancora iscritti skillati
avendo ci vediamo al prossimo video
bella ragazzi
[Musica]